[Music]
so what I'm sure I said Thor's hammer is
out here sitting on the stage what's all
about it I I don't know I noticed it
earlier I just figured the Union
wouldn't know what no I come out here
and there's a Thor's hammer just sitting
here we can't do a show with that thing
sitting there it's stupid well we've got
it's in the way so I'm gonna get rid of
it right so I get rid of it this thing's
gotta go
come on man
[Applause]
I'll give it a try
hey mistake let's both try it together
all right
together okay let's get in there I'm
gonna do it I guess neither of us is
worthy
[Music]
[Applause]
sup dudes what's going on oh hey yeah
well Arnett what are you what are you
doing here what's going on not much I
was just dropping by and noticed that I
left this here
that's so funny yeah okay you got it
tonight stop stop hamming it up how did
you do that how did you do that
what oh dude I'm Thor you're a Thor yeah
Conan everybody knows that um I'm Thor
in I'm also Lego Batman
hey check this out are you ready uh-huh
Lego Batman Thor ready yeah Lego Batman
yeah
now I'm Thor yeah okay all right another
write that explanation went on way too
long
I see why Thor has to overcompensate
going dude yeah tell us what brings you
to comic-con oh dude you kidding me
yeah which tale Thor gets it comic-con
it's unreal and you know him it's Lego
tale Lego bad not no one wants to know
about that yeah anyway listen thanks for
keeping her safe I really gotta run man
I got a got a date with 20 Harley
Quinn's and just kind of wondering if
they can handle it yeah I can handle it
I mean I'm Bojack horseman for Christ's
sake
[Applause]
you
you